let's put to one side then what's
happening in south africa let's uh quote
you from last tuesday when you were on
the program with me you said concerns
are overstated and we will have a great
christmas is that still the case i think
we will have a much better christmas
than last year um because of the
vaccination level both the overall
vaccination level but the particularly
the impact of the booster campaign and
we saw on saturday
just in one day 900 000 people get their
booster um and i do think of course
we've uh you've heard it from the health
secretary over the weekend i'd echo that
people will need to be careful and
cautious um but uh but i do think that
uh again subject to the data and it's
always under a view uh that we're in a
better position um to enjoy christmas
with loved ones this year
will we have any more restrictions
between now and christmas day well i
just can't make hard fast guarantees
because as i said we follow i mean you
said we were going to have a great
christmas last week and now you're
saying a good christmas but i can't even
guarantee that there are going to be any
fewer restrictions or more restrictions
well i think because there's two things
first of all we're in a much different
place we're in a much stronger place
because of the resilience of our
communities because of the high take-up
of the vaccine that's something that has
gone very well not just the overall
vaccine rates but the booster and we're
really uh super charging that through to
the end of this month and through to
christmas so that gives us an extra
layer of resilience and the rules as
they currently are are the best
mystication strategy uh that we've got
but of course there is this time lag in
the data we know omicron is spreading
fast we don't yet know the severity and
we're reliant on seeing that data come
through and it comes through day by day
yeah and we have to listen to what the
scientists are saying last week the
scientists were saying that the
infections could be as high as 200 000
per day before the end of the year and
when i spoke to the health secretary on
monday he was saying two hundred 000
that day
more or less we have to that's now been
quietly dropped we have to um change
these figures all the time as you said
depending on the data how bad is it this
monday as opposed to last monday
well so just to say there's the
difference between modeling which relies
on certain assumptions and the hard data
that's coming through which is why as i
said you can't make hard and fast
guarantees
we have to track the data as it comes
through
which bit of data are you asking me
about for today i'm asking you about how
many infections you think we've had
today or yesterday i should say rather
because obviously we don't know today
we've only just started today not
everybody's up as early as us
no no um the latest data shows and i've
got it here because of course it's
relevant and i know people are
interested uh
82 000 latest daily cases um
200 000. doesn't it that's and and 900
hospitalizations in 45 days that's
overall we talked earlier about the
omicron but look the a lot of the
modelling that is being thrown around is
the worst case scenario which of course
we're duty-bound to consider but we
ultimately come back to this point you
have to test the data in real time
against real cases and see that lag
between spread of cases hospitalizations
and what does it mean for severity in
terms of tragically the number of deaths
yeah modeling that's been thrown around
should we take it with a piece of a
pinch of salt no but we should test it
very carefully and rigorously and that's
what we're doing
okay let me ask you about a question
that actually my son put to me and i
didn't know the answer but you're much
cleverer than me so you will know um if
you have
if you've test positive for covid
and then every day you have a lateral
flow test that you register that's
positive until the infection's gone
through your body
every day that that's registered is that
registered as a different case
um
no it shouldn't be because it should
attach to you but the truth is uh
i'd have to look at the
methodology that they use but i would
have thought that that should attract to
you because you register it under your
name yeah so it could in theory be you
know ten times higher than the actual
figures so you but you don't think
that's the case
look it's a very good methodological
question as usual um i would want to
just defer to what dhs say about the way
that they uh count but it doesn't seem
right that it doesn't seem right that
that would be uh
accounted for for the obvious reasons
yes we'll have to look at that um
reports suggesting 10 ministers are
questioning the scientific advice are
you one of them we always all of us
question the advice and i don't think
that should be presented in some sort of
tectonic um opposition to the scientists
the scientists will tell you that they
are constantly testing the evidence and
the advice uh amongst themselves let
alone with politicians so it's quite
right that we get the balance right the
one thing i'd say is right the way
throughout when we before we went into
lockdown when we went into lockdown i
remember looking at the five tests uh
when we were in lockdown and we were
thinking about how we could come out we
always look at the covert impact the
non-covered health impacts the impacts
on the economy jobs and livelihoods but
also the social impacts as well and
that's the paradigm that we've had
throughout this pandemic and we still do
so you are one of them
no no sorry i fully support the approach
that the government uh has taken so far
but it's absolutely right i mean it'd be
odd if cabinet and ministers weren't in
the meetings we have testing the data
and the approach actually that's very
healthy
absolutely that's why i was asking you
if you were one of them yeah but what i
don't do is banned around i mean i
support the approach the prime minister
the government has taken i think these
are finally balanced schools but i
totally support what we're doing
including what rishi has done and the
treasure have done to support businesses
what i don't do is have those rigorous
discussions uh which rightly take place
in private in the cabinet and then
banding them around because to be honest
with you and i'm not knocking what
you're doing it'll it it leads to
mischievous
media reporting and actually what you
should have in government is really
robust debate and then discipline when
you take decisions and that's what we're
doing
okay um i think there's another cobra
meeting today isn't that the prime
minister wasn't at the one yesterday i
believe he's going to be at the one
today will you be there as well
i'll turn up to any of the meetings to
which i'm invited to have you been
invited
um there's a difference between cobra
and covido but allow me i'm going into
the office shortly afterwards um and
i'll be available for any meetings that
i'm needed for okay here comes a
question about that photograph that's on
the front pages of the papers um
today um at the pm enjoying wine and
cheese i know you're going to say that
it was a business meeting etc etc when
was the last time you took your wife and
baby to a business meeting
well in fairness um i don't live in the
place of work uh where i work so
that number 10 downing street uh and the
garden is used for work uh it was used
uh throughout that week i think the pm
is there seen just after the press
conference he'd done and people uh folk
at home will remember the daily press
conferences and he'd had meetings
earlier i think with the health
secretary earlier in the day in the week
um and you can see staff there and look
um
so it's fundamentally a place of work so
this is not a question where the
baby to work especially when we're in
the middle of a lockdown and a covered
pandemic surely well but kate as you
know number 10 is also the residence of
the prime minister he's got a very young
family and i think if you begrudge uh
the the um his wife coming down in a
break from um the the business of the
day
i don't think that's right
i've had around the door has she sat
down with the baby nursing the baby
there's wine on the table there's cheese
there there's at least 14 15 other
people in the garden
and that's because it's a place of work
they're all in suits um or predominantly
in uh informal times well the the the
picture i saw had uh people it's on the
screen at the moment have a look
i think a large number
to be honest with you look the prime
minister is in a suit um
the officials there but look the point
i'd make is this look
so some of them have taken their jackets
off but the but but kev so it's only a
business meeting if you've got a suit on
well now you're changing your tune no
i'm asking you i'm asking you i'm trying
to see your point of view then let me
answer let me answer okay you normally
do you're normally fair about these
things this is a place of work but it's
also the residence of the prime minister
and sometimes as in many work situations
particularly given the pressures that
the number 10 team are under they might
have um a drink
after the formal business has ended that
is not anything to do with the social
mixing rules and it's consistent with
the guidance at the time
let me ask you this then why would
somebody take a picture of a business
meeting
well who knows but there's been all
sorts of uh
pictures like that flying around clearly
someone with uh anonymous but i don't
know is the short answer to the question
but if you were in number 11 and you saw
people gathering in the garden you
wouldn't think oh that's a lovely
picture it's like a rembrandt i'll just
take a quick photograph of that i don't
think it looks like a rembrandt no it
doesn't it looks like people gathering
when they shouldn't be and so people at
number 11 being a little bit mischievous
are taking a photograph of it and
thinking i'll put that in my back pocket
for when i need it
i i couldn't possibly comment on
someone's motivation what i can say is
number 10 including the garden is a
place of work and they were there
having worked can you accept that it
looks a bit dodge
it looks a bit look i i certainly take
your point that perception uh with the
public is very important what i would
say is i'd point to and let people look
at the photo themselves number 10 is a
place of work also the prime minister's
home
and they use the garden for work
meetings and that's what you can see
okay would do you anticipate being
called back to parliament before
christmas
i don't anticipate it but um
the the pm has been very clear that if
there were changes in the regulations
that would require a decision of
parliament okay i'm always keen to hear
what you have to say deputy prime
minister i'm sorry if you felt that i
was talking over you hopefully i'll see
you again soon i'm sure i won't see you
before christmas have a very lovely
peaceful one thank you with the family